200 years of senate history and this
lasts about an hour
senator robert c byrd president pro tem
of the united states senate you have a
new book out called the senate
1789 to 1989. why did you do this
i want my colleagues today
and senators of tomorrow
and the media of today and tomorrow and
the american people through them
to better understand this unique
institution the united states senate and
the role that it has played over these
two centuries
in fulfilling its responsibilities on
the constitution
we need to develop an institutional
memory
so many of
us who are there now
don't have that institutional memory and
therefore we're unable
to accurately interpret today's events
and to foresee what may happen in the
future
to do these things we need to look
backward
into the past this uh
book is 800 pages long
how did you put it together
that is what i refer to as a mini mini
mini manhattan project
there are almost 300 pictures in that
book
there are 39 chapters
those 39 chapters came from 42
speeches which i delivered on the senate
floor
these speeches were carefully researched
i read them on the senate floor i did
not put them into the record via the
back door
and the pictures came from many many
sources so it took a lot of people
working together
to do this job
the library of congress
the senate
historian and his staff
i've spent hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of hours
on it myself
i've proof read the book five times
no every word that went into it every
comma
exclamation point and question mark
i went over the pictures carefully
and i chose the design on on the uh
on the book
and uh it took
many many months years
on the part of a lot of people explain
what this design is
that design shows
the eagle
and
it's
all on marbled
uh
paper
it's
as ex it's an excellent exquisitely
bound
book
the title is very simple
the senate
1789
1989
can the general public buy this
the general public can buy it
from the government
printing
office
the government printing office has
outlets all over this country
they can buy it
at a cost of 55 dollars
per copy
they send their check to the
superintendent of documents the
government printing office
and they'll get the book
i i make let me hasten to say that i
make no royalties i get no benefits from
the book
i would like to see it
sell
because i want the contents of that book
to become known
around this country
i want the senate of the united states
to be
better appreciated
than what it is
not only by the people on the outside
but the people on the inside
and the people in the media tell the
story how you
came to give that first speech and what
day was it it was on march 21
1980
i was the majority leader
that year i told my colleagues that we
would have no roll call votes on fridays
the senate would be open
we could make speeches we could
carry on business by voice vote and so
on
and in the gallery that day my younger
granddaughter
appeared with a class of students she
was one of the students and with her
teacher and with her father
and i
felt that in as much as there was so
little going on i should take some time
and talk about the senate so that the
class would feel that it had been
benefited
by its visit
that's how the first
speech came about the following friday
my older granddaughter was in the
gallery
with a class
she being one of the students and again
she was with her teacher again the same
father my same son-in-law was there so i
felt i would
treat her as i treated my younger
granddaughter but the same time i wanted
my
my son-in-law to hear a different speech
so i made another speech i didn't have
these speeches prepared
there was no problem for me to talk
about the senate for an hour or so or a
day
and so that's how it came about after
the first two speeches then
other senators who had read the speeches
or who had heard them at that time on
the squawk boxes we didn't have
television in the senate man
and officers of the senate the pages
other people around the senate the door
keepers and so on commented on those
speeches and they said they liked them
they would like to hear more so that
planted the idea why don't i develop a
history of the senate it will take a
long time i can possibly
deliver a hundred speeches on it and so
that's how it came about so
over the next uh
seven to eight years i delivered
speeches
on the history of the senate so that
there are circa 100 speeches
that i've made now there'll be a second
volume the material is already there
because i've already delivered the
speeches there will very likely be a
third volume
because there's enough material
and maybe even a fourth problem did you
deliver all your speeches
without without uh
copying in front of you oh no
no no
i had to
going from the first two which were
extemporaneous because the circumstances
just came
about
without foreknowledge once i had decided
that i was going to develop
the history of the senate
through a series of lectures on the
senate floor then i began to
to read from prepared
speeches
where's this picture from
that was a picture that was taken at a
uh conference
in room 207
just off the senate floor president
reagan came to the conference that day
he had been newly elected
and so we had a joint meeting of
democrats and republicans in that it's
the mansfield room 207 and
the camera caught me looking
over the president's
head
300 photographs
and i think i've heard this from so many
people picked this book up it's one of
the most handsome books
that people have ever seen
the paper the printing who did it
the government printing office that's a
senate document
the government printing office and it's
it has been authorized the printing of
it has been authorized by the senate
via a senate resolution
the
the government printing office
did the work on that
the government printing office is not
accustomed to doing this kind of work
so
there were a lot of bugs in it for a
while and i went over the galley proofs
as i say five times and finally it was
put into
to shape
and then it was contracted out by the
government printed printing office and
an excellent publisher
and binder
actually did the final piece
who helped you in the senate itself
in the senate itself the senate
historian
and his staff
and my own staff
helped me to a considerable extent but i
i for the most part
uh as far as in the senate other than
the senators historian staff
i for the most part then did
did about all the work what's the
reaction you're getting
excellent
senators are
are
exuberant about it
everybody who has seen it
loves it wants a copy of it
and people who have received it
comment
very favorably
with respect to it
give any idea how many copies the
government printing office had printed
originally
i believe about 10 000 or 11 000 copies
copies have gone to all of the
depository libraries
throughout the united states those that
are on the government printing office's
list
have received have received them i have
sent other copies to various colleges
and universities
law professors
where i've had access to the names
because i want that book
to get exposure
where it will be most appreciated
there are people who would like to have
the book
it's limited in number as of now but
there can be a second or third printing
or
additional printing
but there are people who will look at it
look at the pictures
look at the index to see if their names
are in the index then they'll put it on
the shelf it's a beautiful piece
but i want people to see it who will
read it who would teach it in their
classes i want the media especially to
absorb it so that they will get their
facts straight
and i want senators
to read it today and as i say senators
50 years from now so that they will have
a deeper appreciation of this very
unique institution
which is larger than the sum of its 100
parts
this picture comes from what era
that is a picture that was taken
when
mr nixon
was
either senator or vice president it's a
strange picture it has only mr nixon
there and he is
seated in
near the back row
i've never really understood
why that picture was taken but
it's it's quite a
quite a unique picture
that's from
he is seated in the back
area of the senate and he has to
no no he isn't he is seated
at the front yes he's seating
he is seated
oh yes
he is seated in his chair
the vice president's chair the presiding
officer seat
the chamber is empty
there are a few people in one gallery
here there's a tourist there's a door
keeper up here
and
the vice president is sitting there in
the presiding officer's chair and he's
looking back
like this
to someone who has a camera
do you have a favorite part of this book
favorite story
oh there's so many favorite stories in
that book or a favorite senator in
history
i have several favorite senators
of course
the great trio
webster calhoun and clay would have
would occur to every
student of history
thomas hart benton
senator russell i'll have a chapter on
the late senator richard russell in the
next
uh volume
and uh
senator
uh and vice president aaron burr
uh i'll have a chapter on him there are
other favorite senators
but
i think the ones i've named are probably
typical i'm looking for
the compromise of 1850
and i think i'll get it here just a
second because there is a photograph in
here of uh
daniel webster
uh
when did the do you have to remember
when photographs were first taken of
senators
i don't i don't remember
uh let me see if i can for some reason i
can't find the
compromise of 1850 but talk about daniel
webster i will find that what about
daniel webster do you like in in history
well daniel webster of course we had
marry him he was a great orator
we have to keep in mind however that in
those days
senators had more time to reflect to
think
to compose their speeches to write their
speeches webster was a good he was a
good writer
uh and
they they could memorize their speeches
and then after they spoke them they
could take the transcript
uh to their boarding houses
few of them had homes in the area that
here at that time
they
could take their trans the transcripts
of the speeches to the boarding houses
and work on them edit them
so that what we read
is
not necessarily the speech as it was
exactly given this is daniel webster for
our audience yes that is daniel i have
several pictures i believe and i think
he would have been as
great an orator today
uh with
compared to to what we read about him
all senators of today well i think
webster would have been a great order
in any day
um
but times are so different now we men
don't have
webster would not have had the time now
to reflect and to think and to
write
and
i would assume that he memorized a
good many of his speeches as
men and great orders did in those days
henry clay you mentioned him
clay was a great order he was
he was a remarkable man and a
tremendous politician he became speaker
of the house on the first day that he
became a member of the house
and uh
he was
that happened today
no i don't think of it happened today
what about calhoun we've got a picture
here of him calhoun
was a fairy
speaker he spoke at the rate of about
180 words a minute
each of these three
was somewhat unique in his own right
and each brought qualities to his
speeches
that perhaps
the others may not have
we spoke of webster a moment ago
webster
was on the payroll of
of uh
mr biddle's bank
and uh during one of the
great debates in the senate with respect
to the national bank
webster took the occasion to write the
biddle and to remind him that he had not
received his check
and
asked the question do you wish to retain
me
longer now that was an egregious
breach of ethics
in our day
for one in the senate to be on the
payroll
of
an institution about
which the legislation
[Music]
is
being acted upon and debated on the
senate floor we go back to more modern
times here's a photograph of
two gentlemen that used to be leaders in
the senate and the gentleman right here
they just i just saw a story in the
paper about him today who's
who are these two men senator mansfield
and senator hugh scott
senator mansfield was the majority
leader at that time senator scott was a
minority leader they
were the first to go to
china after
president nixon had
opened the doors and
drawn down the barriers
those two senators went to china of
course mr mansfield had been
in china for many years in his earlier
life so
that went on to be ambassador to japan
yes he did yes
he served as majority leader for 16
years 16 years the longest that any
senator has been majority leader where
did you work with him closely i worked
very closely with him i was secretary to
the democratic conference for four years
worked right at his elbow i was the
majority whip for six years worked right
at his elbow and i spent as much time
during those 10 years and those two
offices
as much time on the floor
as i spent when i became majority leader
and then monarch leader and back to my
majority leader i did practically all of
the floor work for mr mansfield while he
was leader
what's this picture
that
is a picture that was taken
at a time when we were meeting with mr
nixon
down in the
down not in the white house but in the
old executive office building
i forget what we were discussing at that
time you can see my hair was not
gray as it is now but it was black
there was a
senator griffin who is then i believe
the whip and there's mr nixon there and
there's
um
jerry ford jerry ford he was at that
time in the house
and there's hugh scott who was a
minority leader at that time that carl
albert i can't i'm looking at this oh
here he is right here
i've been here the house that's carl
albert i can't tell exactly from here
but i believe that's right what uh
what do you remember about this period
about the period when mr nixon was
president and when you possibly were in
this office and those gentlemen
were in the leadership
well that was before
the
problems arose with regard to watergate
nixon
was a president whom i liked because he
understood how to work with congress he
had been in both houses
and i had a
i had a very fond feeling for mr nixon
even though he later had problems and i
prepared at that time to be active in
the impeachment trial
which never never finally occurred
another picture of senator mansfield
what was his style compared to yours as
a majority leader
well as the book will point out
and other people are quoted in it
in answer to that particular question so
i'll let them answer the question
it was a kind of a laid-back style
mr i served under both mr johnson when
he he was made our leader
and mr mansfield mr johnson was the hard
driving type
the
type who would twist arms
could joe
threaten
plead
and
drive
mr mansfield was just the opposite he
was he believed in letting every senator
go his own way make up his own mind he
didn't attempt to twist arms
i did the floor work mr mansfield was
back in his office reading the press
papers and books and so on so they had
their different styles and both were
good leaders that's a picture that was
taken in the rose garden
and mr johnson at the time he was
president and there's the late speaker
mccormick who's there the late hail
boggs congressman boggs
and
carl albert who is
speaker at that time mr mccormick
was then the whip i believe
in the house and then there's george
smathers
who's then the senator from florida
there's the late hubert humphrey
and there's mike mansfield with his back
turned his head turned and mike was
walking away and that picture
was given to
senator mansfield
by the late president kennedy
who wrote on it something to the effect
to mike mansfield who knows
uh
when
when to go
and so it looks as though mike is
walking away from me from the center of
conversation
who is the
new new arrival here in this picture
well now that is the late senator
dirksen senator mansfield was majority
leader senator dirksen was minority
leader senator dirksen was the greatest
orator that i've ever heard in my
time on capitol hill which spans now
going on 37 years on capitol hill
martin dies the late martin dies
representative in the house
who was chairman of the un-american
activities committee was also a great a
great orator but there are those two men
the two leaders mike mansfield worked
very closely with dirksen there was a ex
an excellent rapport between the two and
for that reason
uh we were able to enact the civil
rights act of 1964 because dirksen
threw his
massive influence
into the fray and helped to bring about
the
the cloture
dirksen was probably the most
influential man in the senate at that
time
why was that
well he uh
he was
he was an excellent politician he knew
how to
to
[Music]
he and he was he was excellent if there
was any senator who could who could
change another senator's mind with a
speech
it was everett dirksen there is a
picture
of mike mansfield and
and myself he was talking with me we
were probably going over some
whip check i was the majority whip at
that time
and we were probably counting votes or
some such what's the whip do
well i'll tell you what i did
i was when i was a missouri leader i did
practically all the floor work which
is not
hasn't been the case with other whips
but i i stayed on the floor all the time
and in those days when i was majority
whip
and later when i first became majority
leader we had in the senate uh
the late senator jim allen of alabama
who was an excellent senator
fine man
an excellent parliamentarian knew how to
use the rules and the precedents and he
had the guts to take a stand if he had
stand alone and so we had a lot of
parliamentary battles
and
sandra allen
[Music]
perfected the art of the post-cloture
filibuster
we've all we've had the filibuster for
many decades but the art of the
post-cloture filibuster the filibuster
that occurs after cloture's invoked
and that's
has that has proved to be
a more difficult filibuster than the
pre-closure philip
the battles
were between
senator allen and me i was a majority
leader i would actually
for the uh
i was a majority whip i would act for
the majority leader then as i became a
majority leader
those battles would occur between jim
allen and me the parliamentary battles
on the floor
here's a photograph from the 1964
signing of the civil rights act and
there are some
some new faces here here's senator
dirksen senator humphrey
charlie halleck who was he charlie
hallick was the
leader in the house the leader of the
minority
and the gentleman next to him is that
emmanuel seller
i'm looking at it backwards so i can't i
can't uh see from your assessment
over there behind that
gentleman right here california yes
senator keighler's hubert humphrey
what'd you think of lyndon johnson
well lyndon johnson was
had a unique
drive about him
he would simply
twist arms and
there was just it was difficult to say
no to lyndon johnson i'm one of the few
who ever said no to him
but lyndon johnson probably couldn't
operate as he did
today in today's senate
what did when did you say no to him
uh when he uh called me on one occasion
i can remember very carefully he called
me and asked me to
support the civil rights act of 1964
and i told him that i could not vote for
it
and there were some parts of it i could
support some i could not
and he but he started out like this he
said how bad do you want that judgeship
and i had sent
to the
justice department into the white house
the name of a man in west virginia whom
i wanted to see appointed as a federal
district judge
so mr johnson called me on the phone
he was president of the united states
then how bad do you want that judgeship
well i said i want it
well he said
he doesn't qualify send us another name
i said why doesn't he qualify he said
he's too old how old does he have to be
he said he's
past 60 i said well he wasn't 60 when i
sent his name down
and i said do you remember mr president
when you ran
when you were running for president
i went to the convention
as a delegate from west virginia an
openly announced supporter of lyndon b
johnson
and i uh
i was 100 for lyndon b johnson i wasn't
80 it wasn't 90 of 100
and i
announced it from the steeple
tops i didn't run
had under a rock and i said the same way
i feel about this man who whom i want to
be judged i'm not eighty percent not
nine am 100 percent for him
well we went around and round like that
for about a half hour and then he asked
me to vote for cloture
well i said i'm not going to vote for
closure i'm going to be i'm going to be
with dick russell on that and he said
well you love me as well as you do dick
russell don't you that that's due
but
i said i'm going to be with dick russell
well he said why don't i send you on a
trip somewhere why don't i ask you to go
on a trip somewhere halfway around the
world you can come back make a big
report on it
and look good to your constituents and
all that but you'll be away when that
cloture vote occurs on the philippines i
said no mr president you remember
whenever you were a majority leader and
i first came to the senate you put me on
the appropriations committee
and i can go anywhere in the world i
want at any time as a member of the
appropriations
so the upshot of it was finally as we
went around haggled around for a half
hour
and i would not support cloture
he said
okay bob
he said i still love you
and your nomination will be up first
next week so he sent nomination on up
there that i wanted
i don't know that a lot in our audience
their followers or senator dickson have
ever seen
a picture uh either this young or this
old depending on how you look at it
where did you find a picture like this
do you know well those pictures have
come from so many places it will
indicate right underneath there the
library of congress
some came from jimmy carter's library
some came from the martin luther king
library some came from my own office
some came from
[Music]
libraries in other parts of the country
what made and and we'll move on after
this what do you think senator dirksen
acquired his oratorical ability or the
whole time that you knew him in the
senate did he have
a good speaking technique oh yes at all
time i knew him he did the book will say
will tell that he acquired
acquired this
this
ability
first singing in the church choir it
helped him to develop his voice
and he also
got involved in writing plays and in
acting being the actor in some of the
plays he had a natural voice and he had
a natural flamboyant way about him he
he clowned always he acted with
with great theatrics
and the press galleries would always
fill when they knew dirksen was going to
speak
and he had a marvelous mind
he was he was a big man
a
fairly big man physically but a big man
mentally and
and
he had a soul and a heart for those who
have just joined us we're halfway
through talking with senator robert c
byrd of west virginia
currently the chairman of the
appropriations committee and the
president pro tem in the united states
senate and author of this book
senate
1789-1989 addresses uh the history of
the united states senate
available at the government printing
office for fifty five dollars and we'll
have that address on the screen as the
program goes on definitely at the end of
the program it's a u.s government
printing office washington d.c and the
zip code is 20402
i don't know that you know this but if
you buy more than one copy can you get
them cheaper not that i know of
i know there are here's a picture there
are three
senate office buildings one of them
named after senator dirksen one of them
named after senator russell and the
other one named after this gentleman who
is he and why did you name one of your
buildings after that's senator phil hart
he was in the class of 1958 of which i
was a member
senator phil hart took on some of the
great issues of that day
he was thought of and spoken of as the
conscience of the senate
he often went
against
what some of the powerful political
interests in his state
would have been for or he went forth
by
issues on issues that they would have
been against
he's demonstrated a tremendous amount of
courage
he died of cancer
during his time in the senate and so
i have his picture there i have senator
howard cannon's picture there
and then there's senator eugene mccarthy
there's senator vance hartke all those
were members of the 1958 class and i
have a whole chapter on that class i'm
the last remaining member of that class
and i the class had some very remarkable
senators in it
and they uh
went on to become chairman of various
committees
and as such were highly instrumental in
the passage of
a very important legislation what do you
remember about senator hartke of
democrat of indiana
well he was
very instrumental in education measures
uh
[Music]
i was thinking about muskie senator
muskie's pictures in there too i think
the musketeer was in that class and he
was very instrumental in
the passage of a lot of environmental
legislation there's musk's picture
senator muskie senator johnson is
lauding
senator muskie in the background of that
picture
senator then went on to be secretary of
state but senator muskie when he was in
the senate
he
was
the author of
environmental legislation clean water
act clean air act are you surprised that
you're the only one of the class of 1958
left
well i guess i may be a little surprised
about it here's a
more of a cartoon
of a number of familiar faces do you
recognize
any of these i know that yes i recognize
a good many of those pictures there's
there is uh this senator russell
yes that's senator russell and there's
senator dirksen just behind him
um
senator humphrey's in the picture
senator bob kerr is in the picture
senator wayne morris is in the picture
senator uh wayne morris right here yes
and uh senator keating
kenneth keating
way over here yes
how can someone who is interested in the
senate
and teaching it use this book what's the
best way to use it if you're a teacher
well if i were you know i'm not a
teacher therefore i i don't suppose i
should attempt to answer that question
except say if i were a teacher
i would do exactly what i've done with
this book
i
would as you can see i've read it again
since it was published and it was
published in
february we launched it in february
so that hasn't been
very long ago
but i have read it again since that time
as you can see from all the underlining
in it
uh many people let me uh this is it's a
little bit awkward and and i want to
show the audience because you do this
we once before talked about
how you read the book of precedence yes
senate presidents every year and go
through and underline and i'm going to
fold the pages here and uh and this is
your copy how many times have you done
this this is the
well as you can see i've read the entire
book
since it was published in the last six
weeks i've read it i've underlined it
and in the margins i've
written little notes
uh
as to the highlights of the paragraphs
and in that way i can quickly find some
of the
uh the highlights that i wish to look up
at a particular time aside from looking
in the index
by the way is all the information that
is in your book it is is it all
available in the congressional record if
somebody want to go that route to get
the
most of it there when your any speeches
you gave on the senate floor
they could they could do that
they could do that however these
since i made the speeches
some of them have been
combined in other words there are four
to two speeches that have been put into
39 chapters here and some of them have
been brought up to date as well what's
this picture
picture
over there is a picture of my
receiving
my
law degree from the late president john
f kennedy
he addressed the american university
law school commencement
in
1963
upon that occasion i
received my law degree and i had the
great honor of
of receiving it from him
should you have to have a law degree to
serve in the united states senate no
matter of fact there have been great
senators who who were not
who were not lawyers but most members of
that body have been
lawyers
i learned years ago when i was starting
out
in both houses of the west virginia
legislature that the lawyers seem to
be the movers and shakers and
they knew most they knew
more about
parliamentary procedure and i decided i
should try to get a law degree not that
i ever expected to become a lawyer
but that i just wanted to be a better a
better servant
i want to make myself more able do you
recognize this picture
that picture yes that's uh i believe
that's the madame zhang kai-shek
shaking hands with the late clifford
case
and mike mansfield's at the table
senator dick russell is there russell
back here back there and that's senator
dirksen
at the left and then i believe senator
sparkman is just the other side of the
madam
let's see what we have here on the next
page
that's a picture of president eisenhower
uh having a little
having a little fun and a bad knowledge
and personal flaws with the late speaker
rayburn
and i believe that senator russell long
there in the center yes oops rush along
right in the center
i don't recognize the others in the
picture
if this is 1958 uh i don't know did you
say 50 yet i can't see it from where i
am
but
general eisenhower is present 52 to 60.
where were you at that point
i was in the house i went to the house
in 1953 january when
mr eisenhower became president
and i was in the senate
uh the last two years of mr eisenhower's
second term so photograph includes
sam rayburn and joe martin who were they
sam rayburn was a
at the time that picture was taken you
see when i first went to the house joe
martin was a majority leader that first
year the republicans had taken control
in the 1952 elections
and so joe martin was the speaker and mr
rayburn was the majority leader but then
who was he bill nolan was the majority
leader in the senate
if this these four gentlemen were here
today
would the senate be different than it is
no they wouldn't operate like they did
today if they were here in the senate
how would they change
well
the makeup of the senate has changed
when
lyndon johnson was majority leader
the great issue of that day was the
civil rights issue
and speaker russell and the southern
bloc
constituted
a homogeneous block
and all of the old confederate states of
america
were represented by democratic senators
do you rec did you respect this man oh
the late senator richard russell yes
did very much because he was
he was
a man who revered the senate
and he
was keenly astute to its rules and
precedents and traditions
what do you think he would think of
television in the senate today well he
probably wouldn't
wouldn't have gone for it
this photograph
that
is a photograph of uh
oh yes
john bricker
he pushed the bricker amendment and then
in in him with that and that picture is
i don't recognize those other persons
you remember what the bricker amendment
was yes it had to do with executive
agreements and treaties
and
it almost
a substitute for it almost passed but
for the vote of the late senator harley
kilgore
of west virginia one of my predecessors
who cast the deciding vote against it
that's a picture that was taken on the
white house steps
when uh mr eisenhower was
that was very early in his presidency
and they have margaret sullivan there
with him and beside her there's a new
member of the house sam fredell
beside him
and i see
jack brooks in the picture lee metcalf
and
bob mollahan of west virginia
and
some others
who i can't recognize from here what do
you hope
when we first started talking about all
this you you said you hope that the
press and
students and all will read this and why
is it what does it matter
well it matters a great deal let me
explain
the
people in the media need to know
the history of the united states senate
if they're going to accurately report on
it and interpret today's events
accurately interpret today's events
in the light of history for example
recently following the tower nomination
uh vote
i heard a very uh
fine
news
reporter uh make the statement on a
on a tv show she she was on a panel she
said
the senate will never be the same again
well that reflected to me
a lack of
institutional memory
the senate's already the same again
i mean those things come and go
that's why we need to read the history
we could see that in president tyler's
time for example
in 1843
tyler sent in the name of caleb cushing
to be secretary of the treasury
and it was on the march march the 3rd in
those days the
the
congress wound up its work
on march 3rd and new congress convened
on march 4
and presidents were want to come up to
these
capitol
and sit in the vice president's room
which was where the republican leaders
offices now are just
across from the old senate chamber and
send in their last minute nominations
and sign bills and tyler sent in the
name of caleb cushing to be secretary of
the treasury it was rejected
by the senate by a vote of 27 to 19.
tyler immediately sent it back in to be
secretary of the treasury it was again
rejected by a vote of 27 to 9. he
immediately sent cushing's name back in
to be secretary of the treasury the
third time it was rejected by a vote of
29 to 2.
but that wasn't all of it
tyler's nominee for minister to brazil
was rejected his minister to to france
was rejected his nominee for secretary
of war was rejected his nominee for
secretary of the navy was rejected the
nominee for the supreme court was
rejected and yet the senate got over it
it's
the same thing can be said with respect
to the
imbroglio
in which senator foote of mississippi
drew a gun
on senator
thomas hart benton of missouri
on the senate floor in the old senate
chamber and you talk about fireworks
that may be a pun but you talk about
bitterness
and anger and passion
all of these were a part of the senate
in the days in which they
they were arguing over
abolitionist legislation and petitions
and
and uh the free states versus slave
states
deep
passions
and foot drew a gun on thomas hart
benton
and the senate has been the same since
and there was charles sumner
who was beaten with a cane by a member
of the house as sumner sat at his desk
in the old senate chamber because he had
made a vitriolic speech
titled the crime of kansas and he was
sitting at his desk franking out the
speech to his constituents and preston
brooks a relative of andrew butler
who had been the subject of
sumner's vitriolic invective
came in and said i
you you spoke
i i i want to settle a little matter
with you you i didn't like what you had
to say about my kinsmen and he proceeded
to beat
charles sumner with a cane and sumner
and rising he was a large man he ripped
up his desk and he was out of the senate
for about three years there have been
things like that happen clay
fought a duel with john randolph
representative randolph
of virginia
and
clay shot a hole through randolph's coat
whereupon randolph shot up in the air
with his pistol threw his gun down and
shook hands with clay and said you owe
me a coat
so it kind of makes one laugh when
people
get the idea that because we have some
passionate arguments and
considerable bitterness over a
nomination that the senate will never be
the same again you know that this
if one reads that book there one will
see that the senate
has been here a long time 200 years and
its roots go far deeper
than 1789.
i want you to talk about these this set
of photographs um
george thames
of the new york times took them
and there's a whole series of them why'd
you why'd you include these
well theodore francis greene i think was
about 90 years old the time that picture
was taken he was chairman of the foreign
relations committee in the senate
and
one of the newspapers
had had recommended that greene give up
the chairmanship and greene was about to
give it up and so stated
well lyndon johnson
wanted green to carry a carry out his
decision but
he wanted to make green feel that
london johnson who was the leader would
like for him to stay so
that's a picture
following a meeting of the committee
when
johnson had
ostensibly tried to prevail on green to
stay on as chairman and green and go
said he would like to go off in the next
room and think about it just for a few
minutes so
johnson followed him out into that room
so beginning here at the top
you see johnson talking with the green
then johnson gets a little closer then
johnson gets a little closer then
johnson's a little closer and gene
greene backs up and gets against the
table and here
johnson has green back over the table
and here johnson is right up in green's
face with that
with that typical
pressure
action that johnson could bring to bear
talking right up under your chin looking
you in the eye and he it's a series this
is like an
old silent picture film
and it shows green backing away anybody
in the senate today deal with
his or her colleagues this way no and
johnson couldn't deal with them today i
keep saying that
johnson could not deal with him today we
have a different type
senate
there today a different type of senator
and in those days as i said johnson had
the southern bloc all these senators
from the confederate states were
democrats today many of those old
confederate states represented by
republicans so johnson would not have
had that solid southern bloc backing
that he had then who are these three
gentlemen that that picture there is
president taft
in the middle in the middle and
on this side is
his son who later became
a senator and one of the great senators
whose
pictures are in the medallions in the
senate reception room and on the other
side is another robert taft is that the
robert taft that became senator
the son of
no no that not the same one no that that
that
son did not did not become a senator
this one became
the leader the republicans in the senate
and sought
more than one occasion to secure the
nomination for president
on this on the other side of the page
here we have a
i don't know what you would call this
but it's robert taft again why uh isn't
he the only
i don't know you describe it the the
taft memorial that's up on the uh on the
capitol why why is that there
and could that happen today
well taft was
he was a powerful force in the senate he
was
a great uh
leader of his party
he
came near being president upon
at least he sought
to get the nomination
and uh
he was a very influential
senator
and
he was chosen by a
committee of senators as one of the
all-time
five great senators and
those five senators
are their pictures are in the medallions
in the uh right in the reception room
just off the senate floor
what made what
what did
his colleagues think was so great about
him
well the things that i that i've
outlined he was a very influential
senator he was
was he a good order
no he was not an excellent orator
but he was a powerful force was he tough
he was tough
many people thought he was arrogant
he was
erudite he was effective as a leader
and
he was a statesman
this picture
that is a picture of
mccarthy
senator mccarthy and
senator titins
millard tithing yes
whose son joe tittings also came yes yes
and millard tidings
lost the election in maryland
as the book will explain
[Music]
he lost to a man who was a protege of
mccarthy
and
as the book
states mccarthy's
diatribes and
and
vindictive accusations
helped to bring about the defeat of
tidings
where were you when senator mccarthy was
in the senate i was in the house
what did you think of him
i don't remember too much about what i
thought about him at that time but
i saw him from a great distance at that
time i was a new member of the house
and serving in the house i served there
three terms
i wasn't a close observer of the senate
in those days what's this photo
here
the old senate chamber and i i think i
remember reading where
it was the day that for some reason you
couldn't uh get into the senate chamber
itself
oh that yes that's the old senate
chamber and they were meeting at that
time to debate the nato agreement
and that's president barkley uh
alvin barkley vice president at the time
right here
and uh
was this the permanent home of the
senate at that point or were they just
using a temperament no they were using
it at that time
while they were renovating the
the chamber in which we now sit
the members moved into the chamber which
we now use and on january the 4th 1859
there were 64 members of the senate at
that time
but i can remember coming here as a boy
scout
when they were renovating
the senate chamber
that we now we're now in at that time
then
the senate senators met in the old
senate chamber could the senate
legally meet anywhere it wanted to
well the senate
meet
if it if it passes a resolution to meet
somewhere else it can do it it has met
in the old senate chamber
on on a few occasions the president
convened can convene under the unit
under the united states constitution the
president can convene the senate
anywhere he wants to
if there were an emergency for example
he could convene the senate
on spruce knob over in west virginia
it'd be hard for the soviets to get
there with a battalion or 20 battalions
because those mountaineers over there
like those afghans they
senator vandenberg
son senate van senator vandenberg was a
great republican senator a great
statesman he was
really the spokesman for the chief
spokesman for the republicans at that
time
in the area of foreign policy he was
chairman of the foreign relations
committee
center smoke like they used to today no
no they don't
any reason
oh i think it's about like you see
everywhere else
smoking is not as prevalent as it was it
certainly isn't with senators these
three gentlemen do you recognize them
yes there is
senator
connolly tom connolly who was also
chairman of the
foreign relations committee at one time
and there's senator vandenberg and the
late uh secretary of state john foster
dulles
he was secretary of state when i was in
the house of representatives
i was on the foreign affairs committee
at that time so anybody else we only
have a short time left and we haven't
even begun to look at all the pictures
now you say there are 300 pictures
800 pages yes
when you read this book by the way how
do you do you read it right straight
through at one sitting or do you come
back to it every day no i read it
through
i've read it through i go back to it
many times
to certain areas and refresh my
my memory i also on the occasion of
reading it through looked for any
possible errors that
i may have failed
to pick up in my five five proof
readings
how many people do you think overall had
something to do with putting this book
out
at work in the senate
oh
[Music]
not more than a half dozen i would say
all right
we really put
a good time in it uh are are there any
other senators today sitting in the
united states senate that have as much
interest in history as you do
oh there are senators who have interest
in history
i'm not sure that any any any other
senators have as much interest in the
senate history as i do
i hope there will be others and i hope
that this book will spark
a great deal of interest my interest in
history goes beyond the
history of the senate
i have great interest in the history of
england
and the reason
there are several reasons one it's very
interesting and secondly we're
related to our english forebears but for
the most part i'm interested in the
history of england
because
of its influence on our own history
and on our own
parliamentary
uh
procedures
and on our own constitution
we value
the legislative power of the purse those
of us who are members of the
of the congress
and englishmen fought
and shed their blood
of to establish
the control over the purse
by parliament
and
many of our phrases and clauses in our
own constitution
have roots in english events
and it is for that reason that i like to
know
as much as i can about those roots
because then i can better evaluate our
own constitution and we must remember
that the men who wrote the american
constitution
were fresh in the english experience
senator berg we're about out of time
here's a color photograph in the book of
what looks like to be
at the old senate chamber
yes
and i'm going to
show our audience the front cover of
this book and thank you very much for
joining us book available at the u.s
government printing office washington
d.c author senator robert byrd and it's
called the senate
1989 i mean 1789 to 1989. thank you very
much thank you very much thank you
you